First, why don't we talk about NumPy.
NumPy has built-in functions for
a lot of basic tasks you'll perform while doing statistical analysis.
So examples might include calculating the mean, median, or
standard deviation of an array.
For example, let's say I had an array of all of the integers ranging from one to
five, called numbers.
Technically, NumPy arrays are different from Python lists, but
performing these operations on a Python list like this will cast it
as a NumPy array behind the scenes.
So let's not worry about it too much.
If I wanted to find the average of this array of numbers,
I could simply type numpy.mean(numbers).
We see that it returns that the mean is 3.
As we know is the case.
Similarly, if I want to find the median, I can call numpy.median(numbers).
Finally, if I wish to know the standard deviation,
I can just call numpy.std(numbers).
These are just a few of the functions that make it easier to analyze data when
using NumPy.